elon's obsessed with shackleton he talks
about him all the time he uses
i was going to ask you about that yeah
as an example of
th that is a as an example of what mars
colonization would be like he's right
no that antarctica is as close to you
can simulate that
um the antarctica is as close to what
you could simulate what it would get
that that nat geo series on mars i'm not
sure if you watched it it's incredible
elon's actually in
it um and it kind of and it's like they
get there
everything goes wrong somebody dies like
it's horrible
it they can't find any water it's not
working
so what what is it is it like simulating
the experience of what it'd be like
so it's like a docu-series where the
fictionalized part
is the like astronauts on mars
but then they're interviewing people
like elon musk and others who are the
ones who like
paved the way to get to mars this is a
really interesting
concept i think it's on netflix and yeah
i agree with him 100
which is that the first guys to make
like for example robert frost who
uh uh went to australia sorry
to antarctica the british explorer who
was beaten to the south pole three weeks
by robert amundsen
he died on the way back and the reason
why is because he wasn't well prepared
he was arrogant
he didn't have the proper amounts of
supplies
his team had terrible morale antarctica
is a brutal place if you [ __ ] up
one time you die and it's like you and
this is what you read a lot about which
is
the reason why such heroic characters
like shackleton shine
is a lot of people died like there were
some people who got frozen in the eye
i mean man this again also came to the
north exploration
so i read a lot about like the
exploration of the north pole
and same thing these unextraordinary men
take people out into the ice and get
frozen out there for years
and [ __ ] goes so bad they end up eating
each other
they all die there's a famous one i'm
forgetting his name the british
franklin expedition where they went
searching for them for like 20 years
and they eventually came across a group
of inuit who were like oh yeah we saw
some weird white men here like 15 years
ago
and they find their bones and there's
like saw marks which show that they were
eating each other
so history remembers the ones who didn't
eat each other yeah
we were well yeah we remember the ones
who made it but
there are uh and that would be the story
of mars
that will be the story of ours so but
and nevertheless that's the interesting
thing
about antarctica nevertheless
something about human nature drives us
to
explore it yes that and that seems to be
like you know a lot of people have this
kind of
to me frustrating conversations like
well
earth is great man why do we need to
colonize mars you just don't get it
it i don't know i mean i don't know it's
the same people that say like
why are you running like why are you
running a marathon
what are you running from man yeah i
don't know it's
pushing the limits of the uh of the
human mind of the
of what's possible it's torch mallory
because it's there yeah it's simple and
that
and that somehow actually the result of
that
if you want to be pragmatic about it
there's something about pushing that
limit
that has side effects that you don't
expect that will create a better world
back home for the people
not necessarily on earth but like just
in general it
raises the quality of life for everybody
even though
the initial endeavor doesn't make any
sense the very fact of pushing
the limits of what's possible
then has side effects of uh benefiting
everybody
and it's difficult to predict ahead of
time or what those benefits will be
same with colonizing mars it's unclear
what the benefits will be for earth or
in general
what's struggling get from the moon what
did we get from apollo
right technically and there were a lot
of socialists at the time making this
argument they're like
all this money going you know what we
went to the [ __ ] moon
in 1969 that was amazing the greatest
feat in human history period
what did we learn from it we learned and
learned about interstellar or
interplanetary travel
we learned that we could do something
off of
a device less powerful than the computer
in my pocket yeah like the
the amount of potential locked within my
pocket and your pocket
i mean this is if you were to define my
politics in one way it's greatness
like national quest for national
greatness
there is no greatness without fulfilling
the ultimate calling of the human spirit
which is more it's not enough and why
should it be
it wasn't enough you know our ancestors
could have been content to sit well
actually many of them were
were content to sit and say these
berries will be here for a long time and
they got eaten
and they died and it's the ones who got
out and went to the next place
in the next place and went across the
siberian land bridge
and went across more and it just did
extraordinary things the craziest ones
we are their offspring and we fail them
if we don't
go into space that's how i would put it
you should run for president i'm just
broke space man i love face
no you're pro doing difficult things and
pushing
uh exploring the world in all of its
forms i hope that kind of spirit
permeates politics too that same kind of
uh
can can i well it can and i hope so
you